an explosive new documentary set to air
on hbo
this weekend is reigniting claims that
michael jackson sexually abused children
allegations he has repeatedly denied in
leaving neverland
wade robson and james safechuk accused
the pop icon of molesting them when they
were young boys
we will take a closer look at that
controversy all week the jackson family
will give their first
on-camera reaction to the documentary
tomorrow and on thursday the accusers
speak out only on cbs this morning
in a moment we will talk to the film's
director but first
here's a look at how the two accusers
defended jackson for years
secrets will eat you up you feel so
alone
the two men who are the focus of the
leaving neverland documentary
wade robson and james safechuk say
michael jackson molested them repeatedly
through their adolescence
every night that i was with him there
was abuse
while my mother was you know next door
robson met the singer when he was five
years old
after winning a dance contest in his
native australia
mr jackson in the documentary safechuck
says he shot a pepsi commercial with the
king of pop
right before his ninth birthday looking
for me
the men say jackson warned them they had
to keep the abuse a secret
and allegedly pressured them to defend
him in his sex abuse cases
jackson settled a 1993 lawsuit and was
acquitted in a 2005 criminal trial
in court and in tv interviews robson
repeatedly denied being molested by
michael jackson
what's he like what's he like he's a
good guy he's a good guy
no nonsense no shenanigans but in 2013
after suffering several nervous
breakdowns robson decided to tell what
he claims
is the real story in a lawsuit against
the jackson estate
safechuck followed him a year later both
cases were thrown out because of the
statute of limitations
the men are now appealing you know he
started talking about how much he loves
me
what this is is us how we show our love
for each other other people are ignorant
and they're stupid
they'd never understand the jackson
family has denounced robson and save
chuck as opportunist
and admitted liars his estate also sued
hbo last week
calling leaving neverland a one-sided
marathon of unvetted propaganda
to shamelessly exploit an innocent man
no longer here to defend himself
filmmaker dan reed is the director and
producer of leaving neverland he joins
us for his first tv interview about
making this documentary
is here at the table dan reed very good
to see you thank you so already it's
created a lot of controversy and one of
the main criticisms about it is that
it's very one-sided
that you only focused on wade and james
and you got no reaction from jack
the jackson family or anyone associated
on his side how do you address that
well the allegations are directed
against michael himself and of course
he's he's no longer around to to defend
himself
so we included the things he said while
he was alive in defense
of his behavior you know during the 1993
and the 2003-2005
uh investigations and you know he he
went on television and he his lawyers
made statements and we included quite a
lot of that stuff in there
but did you not think it was necessary
to hear from members of his family or
his lawyers
to react specifically to wade and james
well this this
this isn't a film about michael jackson
it's a film about wade
robson and james safechuck two little
boys who
you know to whom this dreadful thing
happened long ago
and it's the story of their coming to
terms with that over two decades in the
story of their families now
um you know as far as including
other eyewitnesses to that there were
there was no one else in the room
i don't believe when wade was being
molested by michael or when james
was having sex with so robson and
safchak both defended
michael jackson in the past including in
1993
when he was accused of sexual abuse and
robson testified on his behalf at the
trial in 2005.
why have their stories changed well what
people find it difficult to understand
and what i've always
you know making this film found it sort
of difficult to understand and it's very
shocking is the deep attachment that
forms between the abuser
and the abused with this kind of
grooming pedophile activity
so both wade and james were in love with
michael and they contin even after the
sexual activity stopped they continued
loving him and he was
you know close a close friend
particularly with to wade for many many
years and they thought michael was in
love with them too they were
documentaries michael told told them
both you know that he was in love with
them that they were the most they were
special they had an amazing future ahead
of them
and if you're going to be right if
you're going to be mentioning michael
jackson though don't you have some
obligation to get in touch with the
people who have his interests even
though he's not here obviously
because you're saying and you're
repeating some pretty extraordinary
things don't you have an obligation to
talk to the family even if you claim
this isn't about him
well what does the family know about
this sexual abuse that happened
do you think they know about the sexual
abuse but when you're doing it this is
documentary
so when you're doing a documentary don't
you have an obligation to at least ask
the question because you don't know what
the answers to questions are until you
ask well we know
we know that the family in the estates
and jackson during his lifetime and his
lawyers all denied that any sexual abuse
took place and those views are strongly
represented in the film we give those
views a lot of time in the film on
screen and we have people
casting doubt on waves but your main
characters deny something at one point
and then
you ask them questions and they change
their mind why not give the family that
same
chance to perhaps change their story
just as your two main characters did
i i you know what was important for me
was to have eyewitnesses or to you know
people who could add something to the
story
um i i don't know that the jackson
family
has any direct knowledge of what
happened to wade and james i don't
believe they do if they do then they
should
this was clearly very difficult to watch
with many disturbing details
how do you vet some of these details
though because
most of this happened with two people in
the room according to these two men
and that's the case with a lot of
pedophile allegations is you know it's
two people in a room and often people
only come out many years after the
sexual abuse has taken place
um you know i did a deep dive into the
the
invest the child sexual abuse
allegations against jackson in 93 and in
2003 2005 and read a lot of the
the witness statements there and spoke
to a lot of the investigators and i
didn't find anything that contradicted
or cast any doubt whatsoever on wade and
james's accounts
the documentary was also very graphic
why did you decide to go that way
the details of it i think for many years
jackson got away with
this image of being a bit of a child
himself and you know being very
affectionate with children and
i wanted to make sure that people
understood this wasn't
over enthusiastic you know kissing or
cuddling this was
sex this was the kind of sex adults have
but he was having it with
a little a little child and he was known
to spend a lot of time
with with children some famous macaulay
culkin
corey feldman they have throughout the
years denied
any sexual abuse took place did you walk
into this project
objectively or did you walk in already
believing
these two gentlemen you know i had no
prior views about michael jackson i
i had never taken a special interest in
jackson or anyone famous you know i come
from a background of making films about
terrorism and crime
um and so i came to it with a completely
open mind and i certainly didn't want to
stake my reputation
on a story that didn't have a strong
factual basis and that wasn't true
um so so i did look you know throughout
the two years of making the film i
looked for anything that could cast
doubt or undermine
wade and james's story and i found
nothing at all i found their stories
to be very very consistent i found their
family's stories to be very consistent
with what they had told me
were they paid for the documentary they
were not paid they have no financial
interest whatsoever and
no future past or present interest and
one of the criticisms too that i've
heard is that these
two knew each other and that they they
got together with a lawyer and decided
that they would because you came to them
right they didn't come to you
yeah i stumbled this is a story i
stumbled across so i don't do stories
about fame
well i i was sitting down with a channel
4 executive in
in in the uk for breakfast one day and
we said what are the big stories out
there that people kind of
think they know but maybe don't really
know and that have never been sort of
conclusively examined and
michael jackson was one of those and you
know i had someone do some research for
three weeks and
in in a footnote in a forum was this
reference to wade and james
litigating against the michael jackson
estate okay
and that's how i stumbled across the
story and here we are now
well it has created a lot of
conversation from people who haven't
seen it and i think people have to see
it i really think before they can draw
any conclusions
yeah on either side there's a divide
between before and after watching
exactly
all right dan thank you very much thank
you the documentary is called leaving
neverland it will air
march 3rd and march 4th on hbo